depuis hier la contrainte des 10 km est
tombé de quoi donner des envies
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'entre vous ont
ainsi saisi l'opportunité n'ont pas
hésité à planifier un séjour en gîte ou
en camping notamment lors des ponts de
mai pour l'ascension et la pentecôte une
bouffée d'air pour le secteur après
plusieurs mois de quasi arrêt reportage
d'aurélie renault et romain delville g
prendre vos coordonnées pour faire le
contrat de location je vais a besoin de
votre nom de famille s'il vous plaît les
appels s'enchaînent au bout du fil de
nombreuses familles notamment d'île de
france
elle profite du déconfinement pour se
ruer vers les gîtes
depuis une semaine on a fait plus de 3
100 contre 1 et seguer parmi ces
contraintes dans à peu près la moitié
pour le week-end de l'ascension
et puis on a après des réservations pour
la pentecôte
voilà donc le mois de mai est vraiment
un mois de réservation important val de
loire tourisme gère à la réservation de
l'ensemble des gîtes de touraine ici on
s'attend encore à beaucoup d'appels de
dernière minute pour se mettre au vert
l'autre solution c'est la chambre
d'hôtes
nous sommes à bléré chez valérie sa
maison en authentique pierre de tuffeau
dispose de trois chambres
ultraconfortable ouverte il ya trois ans
ici aussi le téléphone a retenti et
beaucoup misé sur le deuxième pont de
mai les touristes veulent profiter d'un
des confinement total alors la vraie
saison touristique je pense qu'elle va
franchement démarrer à partir du 19
puisque notre activité quand même lié à
l'ouverture des châteaux donc je pense
que ça sera principalement à partir du
les propriétaires de gîtes et chambres
d'hôtes serait confiant les appels pour
la saison estivale débute également